with my second time they actually told  me he was the girl and that kind of all  I've ever wanted I do feel like this  emotional clock ticking where I need  this like little bundle of joy to remind  me that there's good in life and like oh  the kid you're gonna do awesome things I  can tell do it this hurts a lot worse  than I anticipated man I'm gonna kill  you spiders so it's a trance Allah oh my  god oh my god  [Music]  oh my god so this video was originally  supposed to be drunk guys eat holiday  foods you're supposed to eat these  things open your eyes in three two one  oh my gosh yeah I like sauce I feel like  it's something that I would never be  brave enough to do on my own walk into  nothing but this  [Music]  oh my god you're very cool what a  gradual puppies  [Music]